What is a protein? We often think about
protein as a nutritional requirement.
You eat meat because it has a lot of
protein. But proteins are far more than
just food. Proteins are made of a
string of smaller building blocks,
called amino acids. Amino acids, are
kind of like Legos that can be used to
build proteins with different
structures. When we eat our food, we
break down the proteins that we ate
into amino acids, and then we stick
them back together again to make lots
of different types of proteins to do
jobs in the cell. Here are some things
that proteins come do: detect light,
form hair and fight disease. Let's look
more closely at three examples. One,
proteins move you. The reason that meat
has a lot of protein is that meat is
muscle. Muscle has to contract to move
our body, so it's full of a type of
protein that moves stuff around. Let's
see how that works. Here are some
proteins in the muscle fiber. This
protein, called myosin can change its
shape. When it changes shape, it moves
these fibers relative to one another.
Millions of these tiny movements cause
the whole muscle to contract.
Two, proteins can kill you. Bo-Tox is a
protein that cuts up molecules in nerve
cells that control your muscles. This
means that Bo-Tox makes your muscles
relax. This could be handy to reduce
wrinkles for Hollywood actors, but it's
not so great when the muscles
controlling your lungs stop working
after you eat food contaminated with
botulism. Three, proteins speed things
up. Enzymes are proteins that make
reactions go more quickly. For example,
the enzyme, amylase, helps break down
starch into sugar. You have amylase in
your saliva. Try chewing a piece of
bread for a really long time. Keep
chewing. What do you notice?